[Musique]
bonjour à tous la grande interview
réalisée en respectant la distanciation
social comme on dit la grande interview
avec agnès verdier molinié qui dirigea
fines bandes consacrées à l'analyse des
politiques publiques ifrap alliès
bonjour merci d'être avec nous comme ça
à distance alors ça fait un peu drôle
vous n'êtes pas forcément très
confortable je trouve que le digital on
va avoir du mal à s'y habituer si on est
condamné à faire des digital le restant
de notre vie maintenant non je l'espère
que dont on verrait alors on s'adapte
alors je veux dire que vous avez
construit votre crédibilité votre
notoriété aussi un peu sur la chasse au
gaspi de l'administration mais pas
seulement puisque vous essayer de
mesurer autant le montant que
l'efficacité de l'argent public alors
aller ce dernier molinier l'économie
française comme la plupart des économies
du monde sort prudemment un dacoma qui a
duré plus de deux mois fera coma
artificiel en quelque sorte on nous a
mis en coma artificiel
diriez vous comme nicolas baverez ce que
vous connaissez bien que l'économie
française est dans une situation
catastrophique
est ce que les dégâts sont considérables
est-ce qu'ils sont à ce point là bas les
dégâts sont très importants tout le
monde s'accorde pour dire qu'on va avoir
une perte de pib cette année deux
d'environ 8% 1 et puis certaines
estimations sont au dessus ça veut dire
qu'on va détruire beaucoup de milliards
de richesse nationale ça veut dire qu'on
va creuser aussi forcément le déficit
mais surtout ça veut dire et c'est ça
qui nous préoccupe le plus en premier
lieu qu'on va avoir beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont se retrouver dans
des situations de faillite de cessation
de paiement et c'est ça qu'il faut
absolument éviter en premiers skis aussi
nous préoccupe c'est que nous rentrons
dans la crise par rapport à nos voisins
européens notamment nos voisins du mot
nord dans une situation qui est plus
difficile
pourquoi parce que nos entreprises sont
plus endettées qu'ailleurs ont plus de
difficulté pourquoi parce qu'elles sont
aussi plus taxés la fondation ifrap a
montré qu on a 100 milliards d'impôts et
charges de plus pour nos entreprises
tous les ans par rapport à la moyenne
des pays de la zone euro donc on voit
pour bar avec plus de difficultés
t nos voisins allemands notamment et que
évidemment il va falloir trouver
beaucoup de solutions ingénieuses pour
pouvoir sortir par le haut de cette
crise et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
toutes les planètes sont pas encore
alignée pour qu'on puisse absolument se
dire qu'on va réussir à surmonter de la
meilleure manière possible cette fait
alors on va regarder en détail comment
les choses peuvent se passer on va
regarder aussi des solutions que vous
ali frappe
vous avez présenté vous avez suggéré
mais auparavant je voudrais votre avis
sur un débat qui est en train de naître
dans la plupart des pays occidentaux et
qui porte sur l'existence même du
confinement
cette situation là n'est pas le résultat
de l'épidémie c'est le résultat d'une
décision de défi de paris prises par le
gouvernement pour lutter contre le virus
on nous a mis sous cloche pour nous a
protégés est ce qu'on l'a bien fait de
mettre l'économie à genoux dans ces
proportions là finalement pour lutter
contre le virus
on n'avait pas vraiment le choix en
réalité pourquoi parce que si on avait
voulu ne pas faire cela il aurait fallu
intervenir beaucoup plus en avant je
parle potentiellement de fin janvier
début février à ce moment là il aurait
fallu dire à tous ceux qui utilisent les
transports en commun ceux qui vont dans
des avions à tous ceux qui vous dans des
centres commerciaux est en fait donc à
tout le monde de porter des masques 2
finalement on aurait dû tester
énormément la population on en n'a pas
pu le faire pourquoi parce qu'il n'y
avait pas les stocks de masques parce
que finalement on n'a pas réagi
vraisemblablement assez vite mais c'est
toujours facile de dire après coup ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire en voyant
l'épidémie arrivé sur nous en voyant la
fin des pandémies qui se propageaient
dans le monde on pouvait subodorer que
il fallait agir très vite et en même
temps elle c'est vrai que on habite
toujours un peu cette impression et se
dire finalement peut-être que ce sera
moins grave chez nous et c est en fait
non pas du tout on voit que c'est un
virus qui se transmet très très vite et
beaucoup plus contagieux qui est
beaucoup plus grave qui peut entraîner
notamment respiratoires qui sont
extrêmement graves et d'une personne à
l'autre on ne sait pas pourquoi certains
réagissent très très mal et d'autres ont
quasiment pas de symptômes
donc je crois qu'on avait pas tellement
le choix à partir du moment où on ne
pouvait pas prendre des choses très très
en amont et à partir du moment aussi où
finalement même les pays qui ont les
pays qui ont moins confiné ont quand
même demandé à leurs populations de
télétravail et de ne pas se regrouper et
c'est donc il ya des niveaux dans le
confinement il ya le niveau extrême qui
est le niveau chinois il ya le niveau
entre guillemets assez light et le
niveau suédois mais entre les deux
finalement m quasiment tous les pays se
retrouve dans une situation quelle que
soit l'heure leur mode de gestion où ils
ont demandé énormément à leur population
énormément d'efforts pour essayer de ne
pas transmettre le virus
donc je crois que c'est un débat qui va
nous animer par rapport à la question de
est-ce qu'on a répondu dans dans le bon
temps etc etc
mais néanmoins on n'avait pas tellement
le choix oui alors c'est d'ailleurs
intéressant parce que le confinement
c'est une riposte très anciens de tout
temps on risque c'est les pays qui
étaient pris par unibet et l'épidémie
chercher à a compilé un peu leur
population pour la protéger mais c'est
la première fois que tous les pays de la
planète décide finalement de sacrifier
leurs économies pour sauver des vies
humaines
tout le monde ou presque à vous le
disiez vous avez raison qu'est ce que ça
dit sur le prix de la vie humaine ça a
quand même changé ça parce que bon on a
eu des crises terribles où on a sacrifié
je pense au caire par exemple on a
sacrifié des vies humaines par millions
et aujourd'hui on a quand même dans le
monde entier pris la précaution de
préserver la vie oui mais on préserve
aussi l'économie dans un second temps
c'est à dire que préserver la vie c'est
aussi préserver la possibilité de
repartir derrière vous vous rendez bien
compte que si jamais on a une situation
qui est totalement hors de contrôle avec
des clusters partout des entreprises qui
peuvent plus faux
au nez parce que tout le monde est
malade et c'est pas mieux donc l'idée
c'était d'arrêter l'épidémie est
derrière de pouvoir reprendre le plus
vite possible et c'est pour ça qu'à la
fondation ifrap dit il faut absolument
aussi maintenir le plus possible des
chaînes de production même pendant le
confinement c'est ce qu'ont fait les
allemands par exemple c'est à dire ils
ont ils ont beaucoup télétravail et ils
ont pas mal confiné un peu moins que
nous quand même avec des règles qui
était quand même assez stricte et puis
en parallèle on a vu que leur industrie
a beaucoup tourné alors pas forcément
l'industrie automobile dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment mais par exemple
dans tout ce qui élimine et métallurgie
on voit que beaucoup en allemagne
beaucoup du sinn mêmes qui étaient dans
des secteurs non essentiels ont continué
à tourner et nous on a beaucoup de
contacts avec des entrepreneurs qui ont
aussi des usines en allemagne en france
il tournait à 30 % en allemagne il
tournait à 100% au même moment en plein
coeur du confinement à je parle du mois
d'avril
donc ça veut dire que l'idée bien sûr
c'est sauver des vies mais c'est aussi
conservé l'appareil productif et
permettent que ceux qui sont dans les
secteurs essentiels ceux qui sont
essentiels à l'économie du pays puissent
continuer aussi à travailler dans le
même temps c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
être jusqu'au boutiste c'est à dire
quand certains syndicats ont demandé
l'arrêt du sinn dans le secteur chimique
par exemple il était absolument
essentiel pour l'eau potable alors
qu'ils considéraient que c'était pas
essentiel voilà on a on a des oeuvres
d'une vision jusqu au boutiste c'est là
qu'il faut bien équilibré mais les
choses on n'a pas détruit des actifs de
production comme aurait pu imaginer que
d'un conte qu'on le fasse l'état
français a déjà dépensé beaucoup
d'argent pour pour soutenir à la fois
des entreprises qui étaient dans ce coma
et les salariés notamment par le chômage
partiel
ce qui m'a surpris dans le document que
l'ifrap à a publié agnès c'est que vous
dites que l'état n'en a pas fait assez
finalement l'état aurait pu en faire
plus
alors qu'en général vous êtes quand même
la première à dénoncer les excès de
dépenses publiques
alors pourquoi est ce que nous disons ça
avait tout simplement parce
nous voyons les plans qui ont été
déployés et notamment en allemagne des
plans très ambitieux je donne quelques
exemples le fameux pge le plan avec la
les emprunts avec garantie de l'état
c'est ce pge en allemagne pour les pme
il est garanti à 100% il est
remboursable sur 10 ans il ya deux ans
où il n'ya pas de remboursement sur les
deux premières années si la lente
reprise
le souhaite il y à un fonds de
solidarité pour les tpe les indépendants
qui est doté de 50 milliards d'euros
quand le node pour l'instant les 2,7
milliards d'euros
donc c'est pour vous dire à quel point
le fait que nous soyons dans une
situation de mauvaise gestion de nos
finances publiques
en arrivant dans la crise avec 50
milliards de déficit structurel avec une
dette qui tutoie les 100 % du pib avec
eux tout finalement la pression fiscale
que nous avons en france qui est bien
plus importante que celle de l'allemagne
puisque selon les derniers chiffres ocde
on à 46,1 % du pib en deux ans en
pression de prélèvements obligatoires
et bien tout ça fait que finalement
quand l'état doit réagir et 20 l'état
français est plus faible par rapport à
ce que peut faire l'état allemand qui
lui a fait des excédents au niveau
social et à en excédent primaire qui a
équilibré donc forcément ses comptes qui
a baissé sa dette à 60% du pib et donc
vous vous dites que c'est paradoxal de
notre pari non parce que on a toujours
expliqué qu on était nous pour un
système de frein à l'endettement c'est à
dire que quand il ya vraiment la crise
qui nous arrive dessus on peut lâcher
sur le déficit et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'ont fait les allemands ils ont dit le
zéro déficit on arrête on l'a on peut
faire du déficit parce qu'on est en
plein coeur de la crise j'imagine que
l'initiative franco allemande laquelle a
été prise cette semaine entre angela
merkel emmanuel macron s'inscrit dans
bug dans votre logique c'est à dire une
solidarité européenne pour venir en aide
à ceux qui ont le plus de difficultés si
la première fois d'ailleurs que des pays
européens mutualisent ainsi la dette
alors là attention
on se pose la question nous donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas plus
utiliser le mécanisme européen de
stabilité le rêve est pourquoi est on
aurait pu aller jusqu'à 400 plus de 400
milliards là on a choisi de mettre que
240 milliards
ça c'était c'était un autre sens plus
efficace et pourquoi les pays qu'on
appelle maintenant les pays du sud de
l'europe ont poussé pour ne pas passer
par ce mécanisme européen de stabilité
tout simplement parce qu'on leur demande
en contrepartie des obligations de bonne
gestion publique des engagements pour
mieux gérer leur compte et ça si vous
voulez cette annonce des 500 milliards
d'abord on sait pas du tout encore
combien ça va être
il faut faut raison garder ça n'a pas
été adopté par l'ensemble des pays et
c'est obligatoire ensuite on sait pas
quelle va être la part de près quelle va
être la part de ton il ya une partie qui
va être rogné sur le budget européen
2021 et 2027 qui représente 1200 79
milliards à peu près on connaît pas
exactement les chiffres et donc les 500
milliards c'est une enveloppe mais qui
est un peu une enveloppe en termes de
communication pour l'instant nous ce que
nous disons à la fondation ifrap c'est
que l'engagement et c'est l'armée entend
les allemands sont engagées sur cette
voie là oui mais ça veut pas dire que
rappelle contrepartie il faut faire
attention il y aura des contreparties
sur la bonne gestion des deniers publics
alors justement si on revient au niveau
microéconomique parce que là ce sont des
grandes masses macroéconomiques qui
relève de la politique économique à la
fois des états et d'europe mais si on
reste au niveau microéconomique vous
dites il faudra sans doute travailler
plus
un peu comme le medef il faut sur grimm
et revenir sur sur les 35 heures qui
sont un peu un totem ou alors qu'est ce
que vous direz lorsque la gauche viendra
avec une proposition de rétablir ou de
restaurer l'île seul l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes
alors hein sur la question du travail
c'est très important de se dire que
cette crise nous a permis aussi de voir
qu'il faut de la flexibilité qu est-ce
qui a été modifié dans le code du
travail par le gouvernement presque dans
les premières ordonnances
ce qui ont été prises tout simplement
l'idée qu'on pouvait aller jusqu'à 60
heures par semaine pour un salarié
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui n'étaient pas sur le
terrain parce qu'ils étaient en garde
d'enfant parce qu'il a été parfois
malades parce que et c est donc un
moment c'est la flexibilité qu'ils
doivent compter sait aussi s'adapter et
là on l'a vu avec cette ordonnance mais
voilà à 60 heures par semaine 48 heures
en moyenne sur 12 semaines
appert que c'était 44 avant et ça a
permis à toute l'économie
agroalimentaire par exemple de continuer
à tourner pour alimenter les français
pour permettre vous imaginez bien que
nos agriculteurs qui ont énormément
travaillé pendant ces dernières semaines
et ces mois de confinement ils ont pas
fait 35 heures par semaine
donc là il ya un vrai vrai sujet sur
l'idée non pas de mettre ton d'allah
allah ou même au même horaire parce que
toutes les entreprises n'ont pas les
mêmes besoins
mais l'idée d'être flexible et cette
idée d'être flexible ça passe pas que
par le temps de travail par blaise est
dédé pourquoi est-ce que c'est s'irrite
restrictif en france pour embauchés en
cdd
il faut toujours avoir des tas
d'explications il faut voir remplacer
quelqu'un il faut que le l'emploi soit
de vraiment nécessaire mais qu à une
certaine période et moi ça peut pas être
un emploi qu'ils aient un emploi dont
l'entreprise a besoin en permanence etc
etc
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire sauter
que dans le code du travail pour
permettre cette flexibilité ce qui ne
veut pas dire que tout le monde va
travailler demain quarante heures jour
sur le volet fiscal vous êtes évidemment
opposé à toute hausse de la fiscalité
notamment au niveau des entreprises
mais il va bien falloir politiquement
donner un certain nombre de gages à tous
ceux qui disent b ya quand même des
inégalités au niveau fiscal et il faut
quand même rétablir un peu la balance on
pense à l'iesf alors que vous voulez
diminué par exemple les frais de
succession par exemple les les impôts de
succession j'avoue sur les transmissions
j'ai vu dans votre dans votre document
vous voulez aussi rapatrier ou essayer
de rapatrier les exilés fiscaux
qu'est ce que vous allez leur donner
comme cadeau
pour que les exilés fiscaux reviennent
et comment vous allez faire passer ça à
la télévision le soir devant un public
lui qui réclame plutôt que les riches
payent plus bas en fait c'est simple on
a besoin de produire en france
si on veut produire en france et c'est
ce qu'on a tous dit pendant cette crise
cette pandémie
un moment il faut qu'on ait des
entreprises en france l'état peut pas
tout produire on a bien vu que l'étape
va produire des masses des médicaments
des respirateurs et c'est ça c'est ça
c'est des voix c'est pas possible
donc l'état s'il veut à un moment qui
est des emplois en france et de la
production en france
il faut qu'ils créent le contexte qui
permet la création de richesses dans ce
pays et de valeur ajoutée dans ce pays
demain si on veut remonter le nombre
d'emplois dans la pharmacie
il faut des investisseurs il faut des
personnes qui vont forcément pendant des
années mettre de l'argent sur de la
recherche etc
ce sera pas que de la recherche publique
ce sera aussi la recherche privée donc
tout ça si on ceux-ci ont fait le compte
de la perte d'emplois dans l'industrie
ces dernières années et qu'on regarde
par rapport aux allemands on voit très
bien qu'on a perdu beaucoup plus
d'emplois dans l'industrie on est autour
de 10% du pib et en industrie alors que
les allemands sont au double ya aucune
raison on est ça mais pourquoi parce
qu'on a fait partir des des familles
entières qui avaient des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire qui était
industrielle qui était sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
donc on a on a détruit de l'emploi et on
l'a remplacé par quoi on l'a remplacé
par beaucoup de petits emplois
passeraient bien payés a pas très forte
valeur ajoutée dans le tourisme et
cetera et cetera
donc c'est un choix qu'on a fait on a
allégé les charges sur les bas salaires
plutôt que de se dire qu'on voulait des
emplois à forte valeur ajoutée
maintenant si on veut une fiscalité qui
permet de te réindustrialiser la france
de produire en france d'avoir des
emplois en france et bien à ce moment là
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on ait une
fiscalité qui baissent parce que sur la
fiscalité du capital
on est au maximum 1 on est parmi les
plus élevés de tous les pays comparables
à on va encore ressortir des évaluations
montrent dans les différents pays
le niveau de fiscalité liée c'est ce que
qui maintenant et l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière l'ifi que cet impôt il
existe quasi
nulle part ailleurs l'imposition du
capital en france des revenus du capital
elle est toujours parmi les plus élevés
des pays qui nous entourent sont plus
faibles
la suède elle a mis à zéro ses droits de
succession et ses droits de donation ça
fait ça permet de transmettre les
entreprises entre générations de
d'éviter qu'elle soit vendue d'éviter
qu'elle soit vendue à des gens qui
ensuite vont les découper et les
revendre en morceaux
donc tout ça c'est sont des choix qui
ont été faits par les pays du nord de
l'europe des choix pragmatique qui sont
en dehors des idéologies c'est à dire 10
fait rétabli et c'est que ça pourrait
résoudre quelque chose mais c'est c'est
totalement dehors de la plaque parce que
rétablir cette ça permettrait quoi ça
permettra aux trois ou quatre milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
et ça va faire encore partir des
milliards il ya 173 milliards d'euros
qui ont quitté la france depuis 1980 à
cause de l'impôt sur la fortune
donc si on veut continuer à désosser
l'industrie française il faut continuer
à augmenter la fiscalité du capital
est ce que ça veut dire que nous allons
revenir il ya un risque pour vous de
revenir sur les réformes fiscales qui
avait été prise au début du du
quinquennat
c'est à dire bon il y est c'est fait
mais la fat tax l'impôt sur les sociétés
également qui est tant qu'italienne vous
pensez qu'on peut revenir là-dessus où
je pense vraiment que non pour l'instant
parce que je crois que ce sont beaucoup
de comment dire de commentateurs qui
propose ça mais qui ne ne sont pas du
tout dans l'économie réelle est la
plupart de ceux qui proposent ça ils ont
jamais monté une entreprise ils ont
jamais embauché quelqu'un ils ont jamais
à avoir malheureusement une entreprise
en faillite à gérer ils ne connaissent
pas tout ça ils sont pas du tout les
mains dans le cambouis de l'économie
qu'elles soient françaises ou qu'elle
soit d'un autre pays
et là c'est ce sont finalement des idées
qui d'ailleurs se sont propagées à la
fin du quinquennat nicolas sarkozy
c'était cette idée de d'augmenter la
fiscalité du capital au niveau de celle
du travail mais il ya aucun pays qui
pratique ça ça n'existe pas prenez tous
les pays qui nous entourent ya aucun
pays qui taxe le capital comme le
travail ça détruit
immédiatement de la richesse a détruit
des emplois
dans un second temps donc nous nous
sommes pour une baisse de la fiscalité
du capital continuer cette base à
fiscalité du capital
nous sommes pour baisser la fiscalité
sur les donations et successions pour
permettre de transmettre les entreprises
entre générations et qu'elle est qu'elle
comme les allemands avec ce mittelstand
ces grosses pme que nous envions
tellement et qui sont souvent
industrielles est qui et qui sont restés
sur sur le sol allemand pourquoi parce
que justement il n'y a quasiment pas de
taxation canton d'être ensuite quand on
transmet cette entreprise et puis on
nous sommes pour baisser les taxes de
production et nous sommes pour baisser
les charges sociales et notamment les
charges sociales au niveau des salaires
plus élevés pourquoi parce que si on
veut faire revenir de la pharmacie de
l'industrie pharmaceutique si on veut
des industries à valeur ajoutée et bien
ce sont des emplois qui sont pas des
emplois payés au smic ce sont des
emplois payés plus donc ça veut dire
aussi baisser les charges sur les
salaires qui sont plus élevés et ne pas
toujours avoir une politique finalement
d'emplois à faible valeur ajoutée
agnès verdier-molinié très rapidement
vous pensez que la préco vide sera
vraiment différent de l'avant que vite
et en quoi sera-t-il différent on entend
des scénarios absolument extraordinaire
enfin parfois surréalistes y aura pas
d'avion il y aura moins d'avions n'y
aura plus de mondialisation comme si on
pouvait se passer de la mondialisation
peut-être qu'il y aura même plus de
capitalisme c'est le capitalisme qui
aurait amené le virus mois d'échangés
commerciaux moins de pétrole ça sent
d'autres plus de digital plus vous
croyez vraiment qu'il va y avoir un
changement aussi radical
je pense surtout que on va toujours
avoir les mêmes handicaps que avant
c'est à dire que croire que cette crise
dure au vide aurait effacé les handicaps
que nous portions en france c'est à dire
cette industrie plus faibles cette ses
finances publiques plus endettés ce
déficit structurel qui est récurrent qui
est toujours d'une cinquantaine de
milliards d'euros par an gardons la
crise du coc vide 9e n'aura pas et
passer tout ça et croire qu'on va
pouvoir repartir à zéro sans régler
blême d'hier et c'est une erreur les
allemands grâce grâce au fait qu'ils ont
bien géré les finances publiques
il avait un système de santé
hyperperformants géré au niveau local
avec des lits top niveau
art en dépensant moins pour l'hôpital
que l'aco les français c'est ça qui est
incroyable et en faisant gérer leurs
hôpitaux publics aussi par des
gestionnaires privés par des managers
qui viennent du secteur privé etc
en rémunérant aussi mieux leurs
soignants donc c'est ça qui est très
difficile à comprendre en france parce
que nous on est tellement administrés on
est tellement dans un système qui est
plus lourd avec plein de strates avec
plein de difficultés
aussi on n'est pas à gilles du tout on
n'est pas on n'est pas géré au niveau
local on n'est pas décentralisé et
résultats en dépensant plus on a plus de
difficultés
donc ce qu vide si on veut se dire qu'
il faut que que cette crise très vite
très difficile très grave et très
malheureuse nous amène à des conclusions
intéressantes
c'est ce que nous proposons la fondation
ifrap c'est de décentraliser ses de
décentraliser la santé c'est de
décentraliser l'éducation c'est
d'arrêter de croire que tout peut se
décider
depuis paris avec dédé brad est
concentré sur l'ensemble des territoires
et que ça va être finalement mieux gérer
comme ça que que en étant régionaliser
pas non donc là il ya des enseignements
à prendre de cette crise à voir aussi
que nous on a en avait gardé
l'enseignement de l'allemagne en 2008
qui avaient énormément pratiques et de
chômage partiel en 2008 et force est de
constater qu'ils n'ont pas du tout fait
la même politique
ils ont beaucoup moins miser sur le
chômage partiel ils ont beaucoup plus
miser sur l'idée justement de continuer
à faire tourner les entreprises le
maximum qu'ils pouvaient pendant la
crise en les aidant avec des subventions
donc tout ça c'est vraiment assez riche
d'enseignements j'espère qu'on ira perdu
meilleur et qu on se rendra compte
justement de nos failles de nos
difficultés et qu'on maquille ira pas
tout ça derrière un discours finalement
qui est tellement idéologues en france
est toujours de dire faudrait aller
chercher l'argent là où il est alors que
finalement il ya de moins en moins de
ceux qui pourraient payer
la france reste comme l'allemagne à une
démocratie
en train de politique dont il faut tenir
compte et je pense que le gouvernement a
essayé d'en tenir compte
même s'il a fait un certain nombre
d'erreurs et pris beaucoup de retard
notamment dans la mise en route des
blancs d'oeufs de soutien est ce que
vous faites mais une démocratie et ça
veut dire aussi un parlement qui évalue
les politiques publiques évaluent leur
efficience est ce que ce n'est pas ce
mot pardonnez-moi par une voix pardonnez
moi je vous arrête parce que on a pris
parfois comme modèle ce qui se passait
en chine ce qui a pu se passer d'un
certain pays asiatiques avec des avec
des régimes plus autoritaire
effectivement ça fonctionnait à la
riposte à la pandémie a été plus rapide
d'une certaine façon mais l'idée c'est
pas du tout de dire que des pays plus
autoritaire en mieux réussi que nous
vous voyez bien que en allemagne ou en
suède
ils n'ont pas du tout été spécialement
autoritaire et pourtant ils ont très
bien gérer l'épidémie avec des tests
avec de la distanciation avec des des
mots d'ordre assez ferme mais néanmoins
qu'ils conservaient à un certain niveau
finalement d'activité dans l'économie
qui a été certainement
on l'a vu sur tous les chiffres plus
importants que chez nous et donc le
sujet c'est ça c'est d'arriver aussi à
bien équilibrer la la politique en
question mais dernière se poser la
question de pourquoi certains éléments
ont manqué pourquoi est ce que on n'a
pas été aussi bons que d'autres et donc
notre modèle français n'est pas un
modèle en l'occurrence il a des failles
il faut le reconnaître il faut permettre
à nos parlementaires d'évaluer
l'efficience de chaque euro dépensé
il faut aussi avoir plus de transparence
vis-à-vis des citoyens pour bien
expliquer comment son dépenser les
deniers publics et de base ne pas
imaginer qu'on va pouvoir s'endetter de
manière je toujours exponentielle sans
que sa grève notre notre système dans
dans votre dernier bouquin était en
marche vers l'immobilisme
c'était avant bien sûr la pandémie cette
épidémie pourrait pts donnait
l'opportunité d'aller contre
l'immobilisme si ça vous voulez dire
c'est que c'est que les facteurs
nous en fait prendre du retard il était
déjà présent chez nous avant absolument
mais ça veut dire aussi qu'il ne faut
pas renoncer aux réformes
alors pourquoi relancer mais entendu bon
faut pas renoncer aux réformes bagnas
mieux c'est quand même c'est quand même
compliqué parfois pour terminer qu'est
ce qui vous fait le quai ce qu'est ce
que vous craignez le plus pour la
rentrée de septembre une deuxième vague
de l'épidémie où le retour des gilets
jaunes parce que c'est ça peut-être le
risque
écoutez je crois pas qu'il faille
craindre quelque chose en particulier je
pense qu'il faut expliquer faire de la
pédagogie et arrêter de faire croire que
les milliards ton du ciel voilà dire en
permanence il ya 500 milliards par ci il
ya 200 milliards là il ya 18 milliards
par là et avoir et donner cette
impression hors sol que des milliards il
y en a partout et c'est facile à trouver
je crois que c'est pas forcément la
bonne méthode
il faut expliquer que cet argent il va
il va peser sur nos comptes dans les
prochaines années et que si on a de
l'argent à dépenser et c'est ce que nous
disons dans notre plan la fondation
ifrap il faut le dépenser avant tout
pour permettre aux entreprises de payer
moins d'impôts dans ce pays pour qu'elle
ne fasse pas faillite au le moins
possible dans les prochains mois donc
après ce qu'il faut expliquer c'est que
ce sont nos entreprises les priorités et
donc le permettre que cette priorité
derrière garantisse un certain niveau
d'emploi et qu'on plonge pas dans un
niveau de chômage trop important donc
c'est là qu'il va falloir expliquer que
le plan de reconstruction de la france
et pas un plan de dépenses sociales
c'est pas un plan de dépenses publiques
c'est un plan de baisse des impôts est
derrière ces implants dans un second
temps de baisse des dépenses et de
baisse de la dette
voilà et si on explique aux français
l'exécutif s'y prend alors des mois en
un mot l'exécutif s'y prend bien pâle
exécutif pour l'instant il apparaît à l
urgence après il est parle de plan de
relance
je sais pas s'il faut parler de plan de
relance je crois qu'il faut qu'on
parlait de plaindre
truction de reconstruction de nos
capacités productives et c'est là qu'il
faut l'expliquer aux français c'est pas
en en dépensant plus ou en parapente en
baissant la tva que ça va changer
quelque chose
l'idée c'est de reconstruire l'emploi
dans ce pays donc c'est et c'est là
c'est de là que viendra la croissance et
c'est de là que viendra que viendront
aussi les recettes publiques de demain
les recettes qu'elles soient sociales ou
qu'elles soient fiscales vous arrête
agnès verdier-molinié un discours des
actions pour restaurer la confiance
parce que le contrat de confiance
il est un peu écornée jusqu'à maintenant
donc on se retrouvera très certainement
on retrouve cette émission sur l'antenne
en rediffusion on la retrouve en replay
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux vous
pouvez pas la manquer et puis sur le
site internet arte france point tv merci
à vous merci à tous à très bientôt
je
[Musique]